taoism is a very rich philosophical and
religious tradition
it has been a huge factor in the chinese
history and also lately in the more
western world
the most famous taoist text the dao de
jing written by the
probably mythical author laozi is a very
popular and influential text today
just as it was 2 000 years ago i have
already dedicated a full video to
exploring taoism
and the early taoist authors to be exact
but in this video i want to be a bit
more specific and focus in
on one of those most significant figures
and texts
not the more famous lao tzu and the dao
de jing
but another one of the most famous and
influential
figures and texts in taoism the ever
fascinating
[Music]
dranzer
this video is brought to you and
sponsored by my wonderful patrons
a few new ones of which have appeared in
the last few weeks
and i'm going to name them now
i would like to thank ashfaq
vegan panus panacion always
sheikh dan hill be not afraid
yeshua dalvin tanvir
thank you so much and again thank you to
all of my patrons and supporters i will
leave a link to my patreon
page in the description for anyone who
wants to join our patreon community
aside from the dao de jing the text
known as the dranzer is probably the
most
important and influential book in all of
taoism
it is named after its author who thus is
also
named dranzer well his actual name was
actually drawn joe
johnson meaning literally master jung
we don't know a whole lot about his life
though he probably lived between the 4th
to
3rd centuries bce during the so-called
warring states period in chinese history
some scholars have suggested the dates
of circa 369 to
286 bce for his life but
it's all very uncertain unlike lautz
however master john was probably a real
historical person
and at least part of the text named
after him was
most likely his own composition as i
said he was born during the very
tumultuous warring states period
after the fall of the western joe empire
but before the unification of china
under the later qin dynasty
a very chaotic and divided time indeed
but one that produced a whole lot of
different philosophical schools and
movements
that would survive for a very long time
afterwards
it is indeed during this period that
confucius presents his philosophical
ideas
of very strong ritualism and filial
piety
further also developed by his student
mencius and which would become
perhaps the most influential school of
thought and philosophy
in chinese history it is also this
period that brought confucius's opponent
moza who instead argued that confucius's
strong emphasis on rituals and
ceremonies was a
useless waste of resources and instead
favor the idea
of an all-inclusive love of all human
beings and a concern for their
material benefit and and their rule
under a kind of anthropomorphic god
likewise it is this period that brought
us the earliest taoist authors and
philosophers
including dranzer or master drawn
he is a very obscure personality whose
life remains much of a mystery to us
but we do get some very basic
information in a brief biography by asi
machian
where he tells us that dronse was a
native of meng
in the state of song which is presently
henan province
this biography also states that johnson
at some point in his life
served as a minor official but other
than this he seems like a very obscure
personality
one who often seems to indeed laugh in
the face of any authority and any claims
to knowledge really
from his own writings and from this
biography partly
we do get the image of a rather ascetic
individual
of a kind of wise madman who would
wander around and challenge people
assumptions about things
not unlike the socrates of ancient
greece or
indeed of yoda in the star wars films in
one story it is said that tronse was
invited by a king
to serve as prime minister to which
drunzer just laughed in his face
and said quote a thousand measures of
gold is substantial profit
and prime ministership is an exalted
position indeed
but haven't you ever heard about the ox
offered in the official sacrifice
he is generously fed for years and
dressed in the finest
embroidered fabrics so that he may one
day be led into the great
temple for slaughter when that day comes
though he may wish that he were just a
little orphaned piglet instead
it is too late so scram you do not
defile me
i'd rather enjoy myself wallowing in the
filth then let myself be controlled by
some head of state
whether this is a true story or not is
of course very hard to say but
if any of you have actually read the
johnson you'll have to agree
that this certainly fits with his wider
personality and tone but our main
interest regarding this man is not so
much his obscure
biography or life but rather the text
that he left behind an incredibly
influential text that has
left its mark on the following
generations
named after its author the dranzer is a
profoundly
engaging funny and baffling piece of
work
it shares many themes and concepts with
the other taoist classic the
de jing but often expresses them in say
rougher and very different ways as well
as also introducing
a lot of new very profound and
striking imagery and and ideas now when
we talk about the drone so as a book
we are usually referring to 33 separate
chapters or
sections which have traditionally been
compiled or
considered to be one single volume and
named the johns
now today we have a bit of a different
view of this
the first seven chapters of the book are
usually referred to as
the inner chapters and this section is
usually considered to be the work of
master
drawn himself it has a somewhat coherent
style and its ideas seem to be
consistent
but the remaining chapters numbers 8 to
22 being called the outer chapters and
the remaining 23 to 33
the miscellaneous chapters were
according to most scholars today
not written by dranza himself but rather
by other
later taoist authors who were inspired
by him or perhaps by his disciples
and probably within a range of about 150
years
after his death but they can also be
said to kind of represent the general
themes
and and style of this wider work
but what does this text say well to put
it simply it is an expression
of that school of thought or philosophy
that we would
later come to call taoism now if you
want a more
thorough introduction and run through of
the core ideas and concepts and
teachings of taoism
i suggest you watch my previous video on
that subject
but in brief terms taoism proposes that
there is an essential principle
called the tao meaning way or path which
is at the center of
all existence the tao is the way and
flow of nature and of the universe it is
a principle that cannot be understood or
articulated
it is sometimes conceived of as a
oneness that encapsulates
all things and hides beneath an
appearance of multiplicity
to the taoist the goal of life is to
live according to the way of the tao
the way of the way so to say by the
practice of
wu which means effortless action or
inaction
or in other words to neglect our
individual wills ourselves
and to live spontaneously according to
the tao and
its natural flow there are many
different books of taoism like the
dao de jing and the lietz but the dronts
in particular is
so fascinating because the it's so
baffling and so eclectic in its language
and it's imagery
the text is sometimes almost completely
indecipherable
at other times it is profoundly
intellectually engaging
and at other times it's hilarious in its
very
humorous and comedic stories but
most of the time it is all of these
things at the same time
which is again what makes it so
interesting to read
in the words of brook siporin quotes it
is precisely draunce's humor that is
beautiful
his beauty that is profound and his
profoundity
that is comic one of the core features
or ideas of the dronzer is his very
skeptical attitude towards
knowledge or certainty in many sections
he expresses the impossibility of
reaching
certainty on any matter preferring
instead to not ask
any questions but to just remain quiet
he even affirms that what he is saying
is ultimately a compromise because words
can never represent reality
in a very famous section johnson tells
of a dream he had where
in the dream he was a butterfly but
after waking up from this dream he
finds himself in confusion quote
suddenly he awoke
and there he was the startled john joe
in the flesh he did not know if joe had
been dreaming he was a butterfly
or if a butterfly was now dreaming it
was joe
another famous section which expresses
similar tendencies
is when johnson is walking with a friend
called huizu
and sees a group of fish in a pond quote
dranzer and huize were strolling along
the bridge of
the howe river drances said the minnows
swim about so
freely following the openings wherever
they take them
such is the happiness of fish
wheats said you are not a fish so whence
do you know the happiness of fish
drances said well you are not i so
whence do you know i don't know the
happiness of fish wheat
said i am not you to be sure so i don't
know what it is to be you
but by the same token since you are
certainly not a fish
my point about your inability to know
the happiness of fish stands intact
drantzy said let's go back to the
starting point you said
whence do you know the happiness of fish
since your question was premised on your
knowing that i know it
i must have known it from up here up
above the howe river
what drance is doing here is in a way
responding to the philosophers who came
before
him like confucius and moza all of these
philosophers had
claimed a dao or way of their own
the word dao at this time was used in
various ways
but partly as a way of denoting a
certain you could say school of thought
or
a way to truth or to structure society
so all of the philosophers like again
confucius and mozu had their own dao
their own truth or their own way to
truth johnson and the other taoist
authors are responding to this by
basically turning the idea of the dao on
its head
they ironically instead turn it into
something that is completely
free of rules and guidelines in other
words the very opposite of the
traditional meaning of the word tao
tao is instead this ineffable thing that
indeed is the truth
but a truth that is indescribable beyond
comprehension
and yet at the core of all being in
another comical yet profound section
quote this is also that that
is also this that posits a this
and a that a right and a wrong of its
own
but this also posits a this and a that a
right and a wrong of its own
so is there really any of that versus
this any right versus wrong
or is there really no that versus this
when
this and that right and wrong are no
longer coupled as
opposites that is called the course or
now as
axis the axis of all courses
what dranzer is doing here is collapsing
the distinction between right and wrong
which creates what at least appears at
first glance like a kind of moral
nihilism but what is also hiding here is
a very profound statement about the
nature of the tao and of reality at
large
to him the tao is one and yet it is the
essence of everything that is
everything is the dao in a sense and so
by that logic everything is one
and this is in fact one of the again one
of the main themes that we occur
in this text is the idea or the the
statement
that everything is one thus all
multiplicity or apparent multiplicity in
the world
only come about through false
association when two people have an
argument say confucius and moza
one person believes that he is right and
that the other person is wrong
but to dronesu none of them is right and
both of them are also right at the same
time in reality neither of them even
exist
as individuals but only as different
expressions of the one
tao so when the difference between me
and you or this and that to use his own
words when when these distinctions
are destroyed there's no longer any room
for
right or wrong instead the only thing
remaining is the dao
which is expresses itself in different
tones and in different melodies
now this idea of the underlying oneness
of the tao and thus of the world
is expressed very beautifully in one of
the opening sections of this book
here the dao is described as the wind
which blows
here and there and when this wind
travels through different holes
and holes of different sizes and shapes
it makes various
sounds as the wind does the shape and
the size of the hole
is what determines the sound the wind
makes
and these sounds thus can be said to be
all of the
ten thousand things existing in the
universe as the taoist expresses it in
other words this means
you and me and everything else in
existence it is in fact the emptiness
of the holes which makes them distinct
and creates the sound
but at the same time everything is
really just the wind itself
which expresses itself in different
melodies again
quote a light breeze brings a small
harmony
while a powerful gale makes for harmony
vast and grand
and once the sharp wind has passed all
the holes returned to their silent
emptiness but this is just the tip of
the iceberg of what transo has to offer
us
there are tons of different stories in
the dronse which
are often very humorous but also
expresses and
some of the the main points and ideas of
his philosophical thought
he advises us to live according to the
tao
which means to not be attached to things
in the world
to be detached from our own selves our
ego
and from the happenings the things that
happen to us and
that happened in the world generally
this means to not even be attached to
knowledge of any kind because any
knowledge will be based on
well language and concept and
language can never express reality as it
actually is
there are many sections where the idea
of attachment or
detachment are expressed in in some of
these various stories in one section for
example from the outer chapters
it is told how draunce's wife died and
his friend
again huitsu came to visit him to give
his condolences
but as he approaches trump so he finds
him sitting
seemingly very happy banging on a drum
ritzy is shocked by this and asks quote
you lived with her she brought up your
children and grew old said tweets
it should be enough simply not to weep
at her death but pounding on a tub and
singing this is going too
far isn't it so drawn sir drops this
bomb quote you're wrong
when she first died do you think i
didn't grieve like anyone else
but i looked back to her beginning and
the time before she was born
not only the time before she was born
but the time before she had a body
not only the time before she had a body
but the time before she had a spirit
in the midst of the jumble of wonder and
mystery a change took place and she had
a spirit
another change and she had a body
another change and she was born
now there's been another change and
she's dead
it's just like the progression of the
four seasons spring
summer fall winter
now she's going to lie down peacefully
in a vast room
if i were to follow after her bawling
and sobbing
it would show that i don't understand
anything about fate
so i stopped life and death is a natural
part of life
it is the way of the tao death is not
the end of anything just as
birth is not the beginning it is all
just a part of the constant change and
transformation that is taking place
in the universe this is of course
similar to the buddhist idea of
impermanence
and would be foolish to attach ourselves
to things that are perpetually changing
and which are impermanent
a similar sentiment is expressed over
drunces own death in another section
and i think i'll just quote you the
whole thing here quote
dranzer was dying and his disciples
wanted to give him a lavish
funeral john said to them
i will have heaven and earth as my
coffin and crypt
the sun and moon for my peri jades the
stars and constellations from my round
oblong gems
all creatures from my tomb gifts and
pallbearers
my funeral accountants are already fully
prepared
what could possibly be added but we fear
the crows and vultures will eat your
masters have they
drances said above ground i'll be eaten
by crows and vultures
below ground by ants and crickets now
you want to rob the one to feed the
other
why such favoritism how can you not love
this guy
and this is indeed a recurring theme in
the book to detach
from the world in our limited self and
see
the world and the universe from the
bigger picture
in the grand scheme of things the death
of johnson's wife
is only one transformation just one more
thing that changes
in this this flowing this unfolding of
of
creation or this unfolding of the tao
and its flow
it's just another expression of the dao
doing its
natural thing but also notice how
johnson says
that when initially when his wife died
he did weep like
any second person would so he's not
denying the legitimacy of human emotions
it's a bit more nuanced than that of
course but this means that he advocates
a simple life one
free of association with things like
rulers or scholars
but in complete spontaneity flowing like
water
or riding the wind of the dao
and another famous and humorous story
dranza tells of a man who
runs into this very big and ugly tree
he looks at this tree and he sees that
the branches are all twisted
the trunk of the tree is is cut or it's
it's just a bad tree that cannot be used
to build anything
not a coffin and no table nothing at all
and so the man deems this tree to be
useless but then the story turns around
or it's turned basically on its head
when the author claims that
it's because the tree is ugly
and and useless that it has survived for
so long
because think about the other trees the
good trees the beautiful the fine trees
all of those trees have been cut down to
be used to build various things
but because this tree was so ugly no one
has cut it down and thus it has survived
much longer than all the other trees
quote this is the trouble that comes
from being worth something
in the expiation ceremony cows with
white spots
pigs with upturned snouts and humans
with hemorrhoids
are considered unfit to be offered as
sacrifices to the river god
all shamans know this and thus they
regard these creatures
as a being of bad fortune but this is
exactly why
the spirit man regards them as creatures
of very good fortune indeed
these are all humorous quotes of course
but what they are saying applies to
human beings as well
it is better to be ugly and undesirable
it is better to not try to be pretty or
virtuous or knowledgeable
because it is those people who get used
and who are ultimately
confused it is through not being
virtuous or not trying to be virtuous
that true virtue is achieved
it is through uselessness that one
becomes truly
useful again dronsa asks us to go beyond
the
illusory world of appearances of
multiplicity and things like status
and fame the scholars who try to figure
out the truth only get lost in the ego
of their own languages
by trying to grasp the truth with words
they are only straying further away from
it
this is why he used so many paradoxes
and humorous stories and parables
to point out the uselessness of trying
to articulate things in that way
everything is fundamentally one and is
always
changing according to the flow of the
tao and
the true sage lives and acts accordingly
as you can see there's a whole lot going
on in this book
johnson is a notoriously difficult
writer and it's almost impossible to pin
him down
is he a mystic is he a philosopher is he
a
skeptic a nihilist a relativist
is he a theist or an agnostic is he
maybe all of the above
we should probably look at all of these
different interpretations as a
conscious effort on the author's part he
wants to collapse the common idea we
have of knowledge and
what we think that we know he uses
language
to in a weird way to really go beyond
language
in the end the johnson has since its
composition become an immensely
important and influential piece of
literature for
the entire history of chinese philosophy
and religion
there's a whole ocean of different
scholars and people who have written
commentaries on it from neo-confusion
thinkers to later taoists and also by
many
zen buddhists all of whom have taken
great inspiration
from this very old and ancient text the
drawn sir together with the dao de jing
and the lietz
serve as the foundational scriptures for
all of
taoism and thus by that fact they are
some of the most
important pieces of literature in the
intellectual history of the world
even today master drawn baffles and
inspires us with his very
bizarre imagery even for those of us who
don't know
chinese and thus can never fully grasp
the
word play and very creative uses of
language that he
employs in this book even in translation
it is a very
intellectually engaging text in various
ways
anyone who's interested in taoism or
chinese philosophy or religion or really
in the
intellectual history of the world
generally should not pass on this book
it's really a classic
that should not be missed the words of
this wise mad man
echoes across millennia and still
resonates today
and that in itself is testament to the
profanity
of the text that he wrote i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you